a conclu que la rencontre de Rammstein
va renforcer la résilience des
Ukrainiens tout en critiquant
l'indécision sur la livraison des chars
d'assaut lourds de construction
allemande quelques heures plus tard un
des conseillers de la présidente
ukrainienne abondait dans le même sens
vous aiderez l'Ukraine avec les armes
nécessaires et réaliserez qu'il n'y a
pas d'autres option pour mettre fin à la
guerre a-t-il écrit sur Twitter mais les
alliés européens ne sont pas tous
d'accord avec l'impasse diplomatique
forcée par Berlin à l'unisson les trois
ministres des Affaires étrangères des
pays baltes ont aussi exprimé leur
mécontentement envers la stratégie
allemande nous ministres des Affaires
étrangères exigeant que l'Allemagne
fournisse des Charleroi l'Ukraine
maintenant ils sont nécessaires pour
arrêter les agressions russes aidez
l'ukraines et rétablir la peine
rapidement l'Allemagne en tant que
première puissance européenne à une
responsabilité spéciale à cet égard
entre temps à Moscou des exercices de
défense anti-aérienne ont été menées
avec plus de 150 soldats et plus de 30
pièces d'armes et d'équipement
militaires selon le ministre de la
Défense russe le Kremlin dit vouloir
protéger ses infrastructures
essentielles en cas d'attaque aérienne
le campus affirme aussi avoir mené des
opérations défensives à zaporigia et
avoir pris des positions plus
avantageuses mais dans le camp deverse
on indique avoir seulement essuyé des
tirs dans des villages du sud du pays
non
ou des gens comme ce couple deviennent
des sans-abris du jour au lendemain et
ces Carla Oliveira Radio-Canada Montréal